this was the beginning of beetle Mania
when a band from Liverpool realized they
could be the next big thing
photos of a few months that changed
their lives taken by Paul McCartney have
resurfaced after 60 years hidden away
taking us behind the scenes during 1963
and 64 the beginning of an era of
British cultural dominance in popular
music
the 250 photos on show at the National
Portrait Gallery capture their
excitement as they take their first
flights to America their exhaustion on
the road backstage in Liverpool
rehearsing in Paris and a holiday in
Miami which bursts with color
at the very beginning of this exhibition
they're famous in Britain it's you know
just a few weeks after the the phrase
beetlemania was coined and then in the
course of this exhibition they traveled
to America and then they play on their
Ed Sullivan Show which is a popular sort
of Sunday night variety show and it was
watched by 73 million people which was
an unprecedented TV audience and that
moment was kind of a watershed moment
culturally and sort of redefined the
idea of Fame and Global Fame
in these brief moments Paul McCartney is
the viewer not the viewed
though the contact sheets were developed
the photos never were the crowds the
fans the frenzy they allude to what was
to become a cultural revolution say
Beatles experts British music didn't
mean very much at that time the big
artists were the ones in America like
Elvis Presley and Little Richard and
such and then Along Came The Beatles And
I think it was the timing was just right
for them it was time for someone to
break through in a big way and they did
I mean their perfect personalities and
great songs everything about them I like
really in fact what's not to like unlike
most photos taken and posted on social
media today McCartney never intended to
share these with the world with his
camera he was making memories
many know what beetlemania looked like
from the outside the smiling band The
Screaming fans the polished presentation
but this collection takes us inside that
time like a personal family album
capturing the joy and excitement of four
friends who had no idea that they would
go on to become the biggest band of all
time Charlie Angela Al Jazeera London